have you watched
criminal on netflix no but i feel like
i've seen the trailer you probably have
dopest [ __ ] show is it a series yes
thank the lord i've been looking for a
new series for time nice quick though
from your bank through it
there's two seasons four episodes each
oh really your bank
how many how long enough i want to say
an hour but maybe maybe shorter oh god
it might be about 40. don't tease me
don't tease me i need something goodness
i'm good at long bro it's not long
bro it's not long um so basically
it's all set in this uh interrogation
room so it's a police thing
and every episode does not correlate to
the one before oh it's a brand new stuff
oh
[ __ ] i love you sorry is that like an
anthology kind of thing is that what
it's called
i don't know every app doesn't come with
like a black mirror kind of thing yeah
everyone's this new story
so all it is is a new case new person in
yeah and you own
only in this room only in this room so
you don't know any of the details until
the person walks into this room
and they start the interrogation it's
juicy oh it's
juicy but i'm gonna spoil one of the
episodes i have to i have to
do that i have to i have to talk about
it i have to
so if you don't want me to spoil it stop
listening in three two one
here we go so brav this thing so it's
got this episode
the main character's kit harrington okay
oh [ __ ] from game of thrones
[ __ ] no he looks buff innocent he
looks clean he's got a suit on
everything he looks back okay
okay okay yeah yeah anyway anyway my
[ __ ] snow
so my man's in there because what a
waste money what a waste man in the
entire garden
he was a top pussy-hole um anyway slight
tangent yeah
i was so gassed even though it was
incest i was so gassed when he [ __ ]
daenerys i was like finally finally
because you know he's loving it yeah oh
oh anyway
she was banging would you uh i hate to
digress
i know people are thinking tell us about
the episode yeah i know i know what i
want to digress
[ __ ] it it's like game of thrones chat
would you have carried on [ __ ] and
once you knew she was your auntie
when you know you can die with this
secret
i i think maybe my dick would have
wanted to [ __ ] her again
but my brain would have been telling me
nah that's wrong that's weird that's you
know what i mean
yeah maybe like after the first time
yeah after i ignored after i'd [ __ ]
and acknowledged that whatever
yeah but wouldn't you like in my head i
would like to justify all of it
i'm probably gonna keep [ __ ] her but
i i'm not gonna be the kind of guy who's
like man i don't care if it's my arnie
like i'm still gonna [ __ ] up i would
have been the guy that's like this is
wives tales
yeah this is all wives tales
like i'm hearing it from word of mouth
between this and this and they're saying
that the baby that happened is me but
like
no one's proven it who's to say it was
me anyway
um i would have convinced myself that it
was all wild sales and i would have kept
smashing her
kept smashing yeah yeah yeah bang bang
bare um yeah anyway yeah
so this episode right so um
they get him in the room and he's
kicking is he a suspect he's a suspect
yeah so he's
kit harrington is getting interrogated
and he's livid
is it sorry to cut you off again is it
american or english english
english i love a good english english
dish when it hits it hits home those bbc
dramas
bro dracula anyway sorry it's caught you
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah anyway yeah go on go on
go um so
there's kicking off kicking off yeah he
gets in there he's
vex and he's like why have you taken me
in here all this all this all this yeah
so they get him in there and basically
he's been accused of rape oh god yeah i
know
hot topic on this podcast for some
reason yeah yeah that's the first thing
i thought yeah
you spoke about that a lot guys sorry
you keep going it's sass in it i know
people are gonna be thinking this is
suss these man speak about rip too much
anyway so he's been accused so he goes
in there
and he's like whatever i didn't do it i
didn't do it i didn't do it
so they're interviewing him and he's
like so
the the you had to said he raped yes is
a girl that works for him so he works as
an estate agent okay
and he's a big boy in this like bigger
stage engine firm right okay
so they got he said every friday they go
out for drinks yeah and she's like kind
of new she's only been there for like a
month
yeah so he said in the story of how they
were out for drinks
having a good time there's him like two
other brayers
and her and he's like uh obviously she's
new so you i can tell she's trying to
prove that she's like one of the lads in
it that she can go
drink for drink all this stuff it's
getting a bit late so i'm thinking maybe
we should go
so two of the guys leave and he's ready
to go and he's like cool
it was my idea that everyone goes home
um
and yeah it was it was a rap you know
what i mean
so um we're all about to go and she's
like nah nah nah i want to stay i want
to stay i want to stay
um bring this up g
and um he's like all right cool
whatever um this is like he says like
where they live
like that place that they've just left
is the only place that is open yeah so
she says
oh let's go back let's go back to yours
for a few
and he's like all right calm he's gonna
let them know like this is all her idea
not mine etc so they get in the cab
they go back to his and um chat and chat
and chat and she keeps talking about
like how far she wants to go in the
business
and how she wants to learn from him and
she wants to be where he is in a few
years and all this
schmoozy chat so he's like cool cool
they're back go back to his
they're talking talking talking and then
she lips as him
so he lips he says i'm not gonna lie
lipstick back she's attractive
i was down etc but i did not force
nothing
okay so um
they pull up the police pull up a um
a thingy uh a text message okay on the
screen so they've got a tv in the
interrogation room and they're like all
right this is a text message from the
girl
to her brethren and it's an angry face
and it says she puts an angry emoji and
the bridge in reply saying what's wrong
and then she put he just kissed me
so they say to him
how do you interpret that text message
and he says
well she's vexed that i just kissed her
i didn't do anything more
and they're saying
well it seems to us that she's saying
that you just kissed her
off the bat off the bat like she didn't
want it i didn't want it yeah oh
this is yeah this changes the whole down
yeah yeah so you're saying obviously
it wasn't just a kiss some other stuff
happens
so we want to know what what else
happened kind of thing so he says oh
i decided by that time it's time for her
to leave okay um so i called her uber
and he was like you can check my account
yeah i called the uber to her house for
her you can check and they're like
cool calm down we checked yeah but we
don't know if that was after
all this stuff and he says and the uber
got cancelled
by him or by the job it had to be him
but yeah she's there by him
okay she's like yeah you may have called
it the uber but the uber got cancelled
okay and then he was like
yeah that's because um
[Music]
that's because [ __ ]
uh what was it so yeah the uber got
cancelled yeah that's because she told
me to cancel it
she said she don't want to go she told
me okay
and they're like okay cool well here's
the situation
her coat that she brought to yours
has traces of your semen on it so
clearly
she was wearing a [ __ ] coat ready to
go when you [ __ ] her
so what we see is potentially you called
her uber or she asked you to call her
uber
you called her an uber you cancelled it
and when she's trying to leave
you raped her and he's like nah
that did not happen that did not happen
he's going nuts like no no no no no
it's not crying to [ __ ] someone with a
[ __ ] coat on yeah like yes she got
her coat on but she's the one telling me
she didn't want to leave yeah
so these man all right cool cool cool
cool
um keep going keep going keep going and
he's like all right cool so like how did
you [ __ ] kind of thing
um and he's like well we just [ __ ] in
like normal [ __ ] he said it was a quick
thing
um it was okay like nothing major it was
just like a
he was like it's one of them trousers
down things it wasn't like explicit yeah
it was just like a trouser 10 quick nut
kind of thing
so they were like all right calm and
then some guy comes in another police
officer brings in a medical report
yeah so obviously they had to give her a
medical examination and then they put it
down
and man's like the police officer is
like cool so when you were [ __ ] her
and he's looking at pictures in the
medical report
when you're [ __ ] her were you holding
her wrists or anything like that and he
was like
nah i don't think so emma says are you
sure cuz are you sure you weren't
squeezing harris and man's like
nah and then he's like i don't know
like maybe like i don't know and they're
like right you into that and he's like
nah i'm actually not into that kind of
thing so
my initial impression to me is like that
i didn't do it but like
maybe i held a wrist like are you
telling me she's got bruised wrists or
something like that he's like don't
don't worry about what i'm telling you
she's got like did you squeeze her wrist
or not did you hold her down by her
wrist
it might like nah definitely don't hold
her down by the wrist yeah and he's like
so but is it like did you grab the wrist
did you hold it down like well your
story is not adding up kind of thing and
i was like i was drunk i don't [ __ ]
know that ah
so you were drunk so how am i supposed
to believe anything you said like how
and he's a big man i know just because i
was drunk doesn't mean that i didn't
like i don't know the difference between
consensual non-sexual sex for [ __ ]
sake
anyway they're going around in circles
for time about this it's getting
intense for her it's getting [ __ ]
intense
so they're going around going around
going around
i didn't do it i didn't do it explain
this explain this yeah so then the
lawyer
says i'll come have a quick break and so
the police go outside
and then um the police say oh do you
want to take him outside to have your
break because we can hear you
um if you're going to stay in this room
and the lawyer's like minor you can hear
what i have to say i don't care so the
police leave
give him a break and the lawyer turns to
him and says
right in a minute they're gonna draw us
for the medical report
and it might say that she's got like
internal bruising
and they're gonna try if that happens
they're gonna try and say that you raped
this girl and he's sweating now
and she's like is there gonna says
internal bruising and man's like
i don't [ __ ] know i don't know how
easily
someone bruises like i don't know and
she's and there's dread because the
lawyer is getting upset
so the lawyer has an emotional
attachment to this case yeah so either
and
not in a good way like she she's in a
position where you can tell she's not
happy about defending him now yeah she
doesn't want to be defending him because
she actually even the lawyer thinks he's
done it
yeah so um
she's like well what you need to know
as your professional like lawyer
solicitor i need to tell you
that it doesn't actually matter if it
comes out as bruised
yeah or not because if it's bruised you
could have just had rough sex
yeah that doesn't mean you raped her
people do that all the time yeah
if it's not bruised doesn't mean you
didn't rape her yeah
you could have just not [ __ ] the
living [ __ ] out of her while your rape
said you know what i mean yeah so it
doesn't really mean anything
so when they come back and try this
whole song and dance which they will
don't rise to it don't bite just let
them say what they have to say
and we move and that guy's like cool
he's stressed fam
yeah and he said he's thinking i'm going
down yeah so
all of this she's got bruised on the
wrist they didn't even bring up the
internal bruising
if it was there or not we don't know um
so all of this and it's
getting close to the point where they're
about to fully charge my man now yeah
because the interview he's looking it's
looking bad for him yeah he swears
so basically what happened is after all
this occasion
she waited four days to come back in and
say
oh um he raped me kind of thing okay
so his like defense is like if i raped
her surely she would have just gone
straight from my yard to the police if
that's what would happen yeah and
they're like well actually no in a lot
of cases it doesn't happen like that
so we can't that's a terrible defense
like you can't use that kind of thing
and he's like all right cool and then
they said to him why do you think she
waited four days
and man's like right i don't want to be
that guy yeah
but on the monday we like i [ __ ] her
on the saturday on the monday
she interviewed for a job a new job a
higher position job
that she was never gonna get yeah never
gonna get and i think the owner
now i'm thinking about it i think the
only reason she [ __ ] me is because she
thought it would make it easier for her
to get that job
because all she kept talking about was
promotion this promotion that oh yeah i
forget that she works for him
yeah yeah she was like the whole night
she would talk about promotion this
promotion that
on the monday she interviewed for a job
that she was never going to get on
tuesday she found out she didn't get it
maybe she was mad and maybe that's why
on wednesday thursday she's coming
separately saying that i raped her
i don't want to be the guy that says
that kind of stuff
but that's changed the whole dynamic of
the show but that might have been the
case
these men are about to brush it under
the rug
just like shut the [ __ ] up that never
happened yeah you raped this [ __ ]
just as we're getting to that point
another police officer that's
in like the back room behind the mirror
is doing research
and he pulls up there he has to pull up
the girl's phone records and stuff
and then there's a random text in there
that says um
bungalow part two question mark and
that's what the rate the girl who got
raped
she sent that to her mate
and said bungalow part two so my man's
like
what's this bungalow part two thing like
it's random they're talking about all
this sex [ __ ]
and now they're talking about bungalow
part two
well no she says didn't get the job
that's what it was after she interviewed
him together job she messaged her and
said didn't get the job
bungalow part two and then the man's
like
what's she on about yeah bungalow part
two yeah
they bring up bank records and stuff
like that
so they come back in
and the guy calls the the other police
officers back in the room and says i
need to talk to you
so what's going on is ah i just came
across this bungalow part two thing
um i've looked into it and the bredrin
who she's talking to i looked into her
bank records
and i looked at her linkedin profile and
last year
she was working for a separate company
for a month
she applied for a bigger position didn't
get it
accused one of the execs of raping her
and they paid her a settlement and with
that settlement
her and this girl that's been raped went
to south africa
and stayed in a bungalow
and that's where she's coming up with
this bungalow tooting
that's why she applied for a higher job
didn't get it
now she thinks if she accuses my man of
raping her
she's gonna get a settlement
fam blows the case wide open
blows the case wide open so they go back
in
they don't tell jon snow any of this
though they don't tell jon snow any of
this he's sweating
he's sweating he's so stressed
so he goes in there they go in there
they're like cool well um
we're gonna terminate the interview now
and he's like
what what does that mean yeah like are
you taking me in while we go yeah yeah
yeah
and they're like oh you can go home and
he's like
i'm confused what do you mean i can go
home and then donny's like well don't
you want to go home
he's like of course i want to [ __ ] go
home but you dragged me
from work yeah to here saying i've raped
someone
and now five hours later you're telling
me i could just [ __ ] off home like what
does this mean
kind of thing and they're like oh well
um we don't have enough evidence to
convict you
so we have no choice but to let you go
and he's like
cool so what does this mean and the guy
at the
office is getting angry now and he's
like what do you mean what does this
mean
fam the most amazing the thing this show
does so well
is they encapsulate current times okay
so
they really encapsulate even though it's
a police show yeah they encapsulate
people's
frustration with the the police and the
current climate yeah
so he goes like i just want to talk to
you like and the police officer's trying
to leave the room and he's like no no no
like i need to talk to you kind of thing
yeah and then like get security in here
like this guy seems like he's going to
get irate
and he's like just he's that big man i
gave you five hours of my time
just give me five minutes so the police
officer's like all right cool man
i'll give you five minutes so what the
[ __ ] do you want to say and my man said
you dragged me out of my place of work
in front of clients colleagues
and friends under the premise
that i've raped someone you told
everyone
that i've been accused of raped and you
arrested me and dragged me here
and now you're telling me to just rock
up back to work tomorrow
la di da he's a big man
like i need a signed statement or
something to say that i did not do this
and this is a whole mistake
and the police officer's like it doesn't
work like that brav like you were
accused
we haven't got enough evidence to do it
doesn't mean you didn't do it
go [ __ ] off kind of thing like what more
do you want and then my man says cool
last year he's like my my he said my mom
and my dad own
a student uh flat okay like norwich or
something
last year the police raided the flat on
a drug search thing yeah they
[ __ ] up the yard on their raid yeah
and once they were done they didn't find
nothing
so they paid and replaced everything
and my mom said when she went back in
there on the monday it was
better looking than it ever was okay
and the um they just put everything back
the way it was
and the police officer was like yeah
because she was inconvenienced and man
was like
i was [ __ ] inconvenienced don just
because i didn't rape her
being accused in this day and age that's
not enough yeah
not getting charged is not enough if i
want to keep my job
and keep my friends and keep my
livelihood you need to write something
on a piece of paper or br bring me back
to work tomorrow
you come in to work with me tomorrow and
tell everyone that i didn't do it
no [ __ ] basically says that's your
business whatever happens to you now
is your business a man
man goes mad he gets dragged out by
security
he gets dragged out of the room and i
was thinking
bro that's so accurate like you can't
just get arrested in your place of work
and
be expected to walk up there tonight
yeah the next day with people not asking
you questions
you can't keep your job you cannot keep
yourself you can't keep it you don't get
to keep your job
if someone came into my work and said
we're accusing you of rape we're
arresting you on the premise that you've
raped someone
who works here and dragging me out in
front of everyone
and i'm like i didn't do it yes
or no stop fam bear man in there and
you're like i didn't do it
get off me i didn't do it and you look
at your boss and she's like
and you're like i promise i didn't do it
you can't go back in there tomorrow
anything you do or say
anything you do or say nah
you're sad regardless if you didn't do
it you're sacked
you're the hot topic now you can't get
hired anywhere
of course not you need references you
need
references look at the house fam his
life is ruined
because this one yacht said he did
something that he didn't do
these streets are unforgiving the game
is the game is the game
that game's dirty i know i know that's
foul play that's why i don't want to be
anyone's boss
that's foul play fam
just so my girl can see bungalow tutu
bungalow part two how nice was this
bungalow it must have been
banging fam couldn't believe it
my my man's life was ruined
ruined i would have banged her in her
face the next day
at work i'm finding out where she lives
i'm finding out where she lives
no one can stop me no one can stop i'm
finding out where the [ __ ]
tough she here